this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
when we get to Q&A session a little bit
later we'll take questions both from the
live audience here and also from people
who are watching over the web and can
can send their questions that way so
we're here tonight to celebrate and to
congratulate Andy bechtolsheim for his
induction as a Stanford engineering hero
the Stanford engineering heroes program
was started actually just two years ago
and it's intended to recognize engineers
who have a affiliation either as a
student or as a faculty member or in
some other way with the School of
Engineering to recognize people who have
advanced the course of human social and
economic progress through engineering
and if the 16 Heroes to date you'll
recognize many of the names these are
people like Bill Hewlett and Dave
Packard Vint Cerf Brad Parkinson who was
the inventor of the GPS systems and
Intel former CEO Craig Barrett and so
it's a very distinguished group of
people and were delighted tonight to
welcome Andy into that group unlike many
award events when we celebrate these
heroes we simply ask them how they would
like to spend some time at Stanford and
Andy chose today to spend some time with
some of our students in EE and CS
primarily and have dinner with them and
then talk about life and talk about
starting companies and start to talk
about venture capital and so on and then
he said he would like to give us give us
a talk this evening on the process of
innovation and this is a topic obviously
that is a tremendous interest to the
School of Engineering and to all of us
here and so we're just delighted that
Andy picked that the topic of his talk
which you see up here so Andy as all of
you know I think is probably best known
as a founder or first known perhaps as
one of the founders of Sun Microsystems
but his reputation and his experience
extends well beyond that that company
he's co-founded three companies since
then and the most recent being title you
see up here Arista networks which is a
company that's involved in cloud
networking where he's currently chairman
and chief development officer
Andi is also rather legendary venture
investor he often recognizes before many
of the rest of us the opportunity and
the potential of an idea and there are
many many examples he may talk about
some of them this evening but the one of
course that probably his best-known is
he recognized the potential of a couple
of other Stanford students who formed a
little company that is now called Google
and Andy was the first investor in that
company his career is a technology
innovator and entrepreneur actually
started when he was in high school in
Germany at age 16 he developed a
microprocessor based system that could
be programmed to control milling machine
and he licensed the system to a local
manufacturer and it turned out by the
time he graduate from high school he was
actually making more money than his
father was through his entrepreneurial
activities so not surprisingly that laid
Andy to think about a career in computer
science
he studied Electrical Engineering at the
Technical University of Munich and then
received a Fulbright scholarship to come
to the United States and first he went
to Carnegie Mellon where he got a
master's degree in 1976 and then he came
to Silicon Valley in 1977 and I guess
he's been here ever since he took a
summer job actually here at Stanford
when he first arrived but that fall he
enrolled here as a PhD student and in EE
and CS and his advisor was Forest basket
now who was a faculty member at the time
and is now in the venture capitalists in
Silicon Valley in his own right and he
was telling me over dinner that this was
a very propitious connection that he
made with forests because it turns out
that forest was on sabbatical the for
the first year that he was here or
something and so and he actually got to
use his office for his her his graduate
work and so I think that that says
something while picking the right PhD
advisor so Andy has received many many
honors for his work in the valley here
and for starting companies for mentoring
young people he's received the Stanford
entrepreneurial company of the Year
award the Smithsonian Leadership Award
and he's a member of the National
Academy of Engineering which is really
the highest honor that can be
to to an engineer so tonight we
celebrate him as the most recent of the
Stanford engineering heroes and Andy we
have for you a replica of the plaque
which hangs on the wall just down the
wall here where we have sort of a hero's
wall and so thank you for coming back to
Stanford and we're all looking forward
to your talk this evening and thank you
for the very very kind introduction and
thank you all for coming you know and
when I was young if she grew up on a
farm in Germany and as a young person I
decided the most interesting thing is
that she figured how things work so I
you know started life taking my dad's
tape recorder apart and putting it back
together and so on but I was mostly
interested in computers and this was
back in the 60s when you know personal
computers was just a dream so I always
wanted to learn more about computers
which is why I came to the States and I
I guess I picked the red school here I
was also interested in in how to
translate this kind of knowledge to a
business venture which is what I did
afterwards but what I want to talk to
you about is the the essence of you know
innovation all the kind of good things
that happened here and it's impossible
to start talking about this without
showing a picture of the great
University where we are which arguably
has generated more innovations and more
startups and and more business successes
than any other University on the planet
so the statistics are still forthcoming
but there's a person in the business
school who's actually writing a book
about this and I think it's now ten
thousands of companies that can be
traced back to Stanford alumni and and
Stanford students and central faculty
and and having a connection with
Stanford that employee in our means of
people I I just picked a few of the
better-known logos up here that that
first came to mind but again there's
hundreds or thousands of companies
behind this
when this particular mention in video
which is one of the persons here
sponsoring having sponsored this
beautiful billing Bay and now this is a
so this is sort of the quiz question
which is how many startups really came
out of Stanford I used to think it was
thousands so the there's an official
count on the Stanford innovation website
which is six thousand but according to
chuck loosely that's running the book
it's actually closer to 40 thousand so I
haven't seen the whole list yet but
basically it is just the innovation
center of the universe and it certainly
helps to be in Silicon Valley for this
but you know going back to technology
the the the areas that I'm most familiar
with certainly is and what really drove
this this this revolution that we have
all witnessed is a combination of chip
technology you know there was just an
incredible progress there then a
networking communication the whole web
effect and ultimately open source
software which enabled people to to work
together more more fruitfully to develop
new things and there is this Fountain of
Youth here in Silicon Valley knowns that
known as Moore's law that really
underpins a lot of what has happened
here and I just want to spend a few
minutes to explain it so dr. Moore
actually came up with the city even
before his co-founded Intel that the
number of transistors would double I
think was ruined doubled every year but
it's really every two years and he
predicted this back in 1965 and they
barely knew how to make an integrated
circuit now if you look at the curve so
that the dotted diagonal line is his
prediction his model and that the big
dots are the various microprocessors
that in terms of number of transistors
and at the time they started coming out
of the shipping what you can see that is
for the last 40 years the evolution of
microprocessors was straight on this
line is it's an amazing ability to
predict the future four years in advance
if this improvement is a factor of 1
million in 40 years so if you double
every two years its effective at
thousand every twenty years and a
thousand times 1000 is a million there
hasn't been anything like this in the
history of mankind I think that's safe
to say and basically you can buy you
know
a million times the transistor count of
the compute power today for the same
cost as you know 40 years ago which is
the most amazing cost reduction now the
good news here is that this this curve
is continuing so we're not at the end of
Moore's Law there's a industry
semiconductor association that sort of
publishes these roadmaps which involve
the work of a lot of people on the
manufacturing equipment sides in the
process side and design tools and
everything and at least for the next 12
years it's sort of in the back basically
we would expect another effect of 100
between now and 2020 to 2023 meaning the
the cost of you know computing would go
down that much just the next 12 years
now there's reason to believe that it
doesn't end in 12 years either it's just
that the industry roadmap doesn't go any
further so maybe by the time I truly
retire it will be another fact of a
thousand in the next 20 years
which would be then altogether effect of
a billion from from you know the start
in 1971 so this is really really
unbelievable
and you know it kind of raises the
question there what could you do with a
trillion transistors on a chip
so one thing of course this one can
build bigger memory chips in fact
today's memory chips are pretty dense
already the latest flash chips store 64
gigabits per silicon chip and then they
put eight of them into a package that
looks as one package but it's actually
eight die so there would be 64 gigabytes
in the package that's today they're
predicting you know tunas 50 gigabytes
in 2014 and a terabyte in 2016 so your
future you know iPhone or whatever will
have a terabyte just in a few years on
the on the CPU side it usually comes
down to more cores could be special
function units could be floating point
could be peril units but basically a
factor of 100 next 10 to 12 years and
this is a logarithmic curve so it looks
like a straight line but it's actually a
logarithmic scale a a linearized it here
to make a little more clear what's going
on here so the today's Intel chip has
eight cores per per socket 16 cores in
the dual socket the next one have 16
cores in the socket you know the one
after that 32 and so on and it's just
amazing how these
continuously improving you know
exponential kind of functions what
happens ten years later so based on this
prediction a thousand course in 2022 and
of course at the inverse cost so again
if it costs too much to compute
something today it will be hundred times
cheaper in just ten years
so summary here you know the Moore's law
is a life and well we don't have to
worry about the future yet we have seen
them in fold advanced just the last
forty years and we expect at least
another factor 100 the next twelve years
if not effect of a thousand in the next
twenty years and it truly hasn't been
anything like this anywhere else on the
planet now let's talk about how this
then played out at the at the system
level and for those of you who remember
you know those were the 70s the first
Apple one wooden box not the defense's
today but it actually worked over at
Xerox PARC that much more fancy machine
known as the Palo Alto computer was the
first workstation which was a great
inspiration to me seeing that in action
there in the 80s we had the Apple
Macintosh IBM pcs and in Sun
workstations in the 1990s we had laptops
and cell phones and mp3 players and in
2000 we have iPods iPhones and iPads so
there's a clear clear evolution here to
mobility you know miniaturization things
getting smaller and and it what is true
about this is that you know today's
iPhone iPad has it's a horsepower that
far exceeds the laptop from ten years
ago or the workstation from 20 years ago
it's no comparison so so that's all on a
stood on a communication side things
actually took a little longer so for
those of you remember this the ARPANET
was actually conceived of as a memo in
1965 it took four years to build some
what were they called again some box
that could send a message to each other
and then Vint Cerf who is another alumna
here invented ET CBP in 73 because
they're about to run out of the 8-bit
addressing it was the original ARPANET
was limited to 256 nodes and then you
know it took a while for this okay so
that the ARPANET in 1971
you can still see Stanford on this list
that was actually 13 universities
connected and email
you could transfer files it was actually
quite very useful fifty six kilowatt
lines but it it still worked offering at
1976 I think that's a head about a fifty
seven notes connected back then again
all universities in 1977 it got a little
bigger it really fit on the slide and
then you know what had to change
protocols because of the original
ARPANET Edwards limitation today this is
a picture from Facebook of their
simultaneous users and Hammond users in
the world of where is online talking to
each other you know people are
everywhere except at the on top artists
and the North Pole but every other point
on the planet is connected I think they
even have internet on the on the South
Pole they must have it there okay so
everybody's connected today and
everybody can use all these things that
were you know available only to academia
back then now Ethernet which is the way
that computers actually talk to each
other at least in the in the data center
also took a long time to really took off
so was invented in 1973 at search spark
web but medical the first version was
three megabits the first industry was
that was 10 megabits now a personal
story here so I was a student and
message students at Carnegie Mellon and
my my thesis adviser was Sam fuller was
another graduate from Stanford and he
did visit you know his old alma mater
and he had a chance to stop it's York
spark and he came back to Carnegie
saying he has in the future and it was
Ethernet it's like this cable it was
just connect things because back then it
was inconceivable that it would be that
simple it just at this one cable and
little did I know that I'm here I am
here today 35 was it for 40 almost 40
years later and I'm still working on the
same thing so it's just a little faster
now
but fiber communication you know the the
first Lobos fiber was in mint in 1965
the initial fiber said 20 DB loss per
kilometer which means you couldn't
connect anything more than a few hundred
meters the first really low loss cable
came in the mid 70s so back then you
know they didn't have fiber right
this really took off in the 80s and 90s
and the day of course was tense WM
wavelength division multiplexed you can
be terabytes over one fiber so one thing
one can learn from you know the the old
days that is it can take a couple of
years and particularly in all the
examples I showed you took at least
three if not five years from the day of
invention of
- the first prototype and another three
to five years to get into any kind of
commercial adoption and then another
five years if not longer to get the
white skill adoptions so in the old
dears in the old era you know it could
easily take ten to twenty years for a
new idea to come to real fruition
commercially speaking but everything
changed with the web so in in web time
if things happen a little faster so
let's go to history of web browsers Tim
berners-lee invented the first browser
at CERN in 1990 was imported to UNIX
indocin 91 then then they added graphics
at display things which was very useful
and in any three Marc Andreessen did the
first release of mosaic at NCSA in 94 he
found a Netscape in 95 even public so
it's time from enough startup to IPO one
year and that those were the good old
days
now one thing to keep in mind is there
was a lot of vet browsers at the time
there was at least 30 browsers things
like the sherlock browser or the you
know planet web and get it right
none of this of course man anymore but
you know Netscape won that war the first
run at least accept them it's sort of
one mistake which is that the business
model event was actually not sustainable
because then Microsoft was just going to
give it away right and the other thing
they missed is that the front page was
actually the most useful thing because
they could have done some search button
there but they didn't take advantage of
that
so the unsolved from at that time and
this is now 1995 for us how do you
actually find anything on internet not
back then you know there wasn't that
many sites so if you knew where to go to
you know you could find this stuff and
you know we had Yahoo which was the
first sort of IPO company that organized
the web's information and it was
actually a very well received service at
the time meaning you could actually find
stuff and it was like a newspaper right
they would have editors they would
select the best of websites and put them
into the sports column or the business
column and so on but to find random
stuff that wasn't categorized you know
there was Alta Vista
I mean if you remember that it was an
engine where they still looked all the
keywords you know in the page and you
know you type in the word and would see
which documents in the in their index
would match it and then will
these documents but the problem was that
as soon as people realize how the
algorithm worked they would add these
sort of dark pages behind the documents
it would be the whole dictionary so
whatever you search for I mean the code
was to get to the top screen so that you
would click on it at random but pretty
soon at least I remember I couldn't find
anything on Alta Vista because you know
everything it just got overloaded by
this sort of dark page spam thing so
then there were all kinds of search
engines you know so you know that
crawler Infoseek is really work pretty
well
Lykos Alta Vista dog pile Northern Light
Indian X and then there was Google so
Google was not the first ancient search
and it was actually the last one it's
most people don't realize this and and
Google you know back then this is 98 now
looks pretty much the same it looks
today you know here's the search button
here say I'm feeling lucky but now they
have the social web thing on top but but
basically the the essence of their idea
and the business plan was that to really
find stuff you know it's it's really
important to be able to find stuff on
the internet and in particular as there
was going to be billions of web pages
and you can't do it manually to sort
this so it has to be some automatic way
and the basic notion which is just like
in scientific publishing which is it
doesn't matter how many papers you write
it matters so many people cite your
paper apply to the web you know what's
the solution so the whole PageRank
algorithm was the essence of the
technology and it did work really well
now the second idea of course was that
one you're searching for stuff if you
then find a relevant ad that corresponds
to what you're looking for that also
should be pretty effective and you know
sure enough even today sponsored link
advertisement Google is except for free
email which is the cheapest is still the
most cost effective way to reach a large
audience it's unbelievable fact if it's
just the whole essence of Google's
growth and success in the market so a
great story and and interesting enough
you know Google what's building
abilities but the company really took
off only after the dot-com crash in fact
it made very little money before 2001
because in the old days people spend
mostly advertising dollar on banner ads
in all of the Yahoo
it's where you never really click on but
you gets of an image like TV advertising
but then you know when when the dot-com
crash hit people realized they wanted to
have more effective advertising and
sponsored links and and relevant links
which is much more effective than banner
ads so that's Google that is there was
this other little problem how do you
besides finding the things on the net
how do you find the people on the
internet and sure enough there was at
least a hundred social networking sites
since 1997 and again the one that is by
far the most successful one was not the
first one but it was pretty much the
last one it got started Facebook was
really only becoming available outside
of Harvard and a few places in 2006 just
five five six years ago and obviously
they have now almost a billion users
with 100 billion pictures adding two
hundred fifty minute pictures a day so
it's a huge success in terms of the
number of people using it and obviously
when public recently so lessons to learn
here is that on the web the time from
invention to adoption can be very very
short and you do not have to be the
first to succeed but you have to solve
the right problem and that is being
first - that is basically the most
important thing and then keeping it up
with ongoing innovation on the web so
this digital history of the web and and
systems and and Moore's Law now I want
to switch to you know what what do
people do to actually accelerate
innovation in in their respective
companies and there's different ways of
doing this one is you can start your own
company so if you have that opportunity
that's always a great one there's a lot
of advantages of being a startup company
one is if a complete white sheet of
paper if no install base you have no
customers no legacy systems you can use
the best technology that exists today to
solve the right problem you have no
resources wasted on cast things and your
entire little company is focused on this
just one new idea so this has worked
well for a lot of people especially in
in this valley now there are some
disadvantages which is you know you're
small you have very limited resources
most people and money you dependent on
canvas of strangers and it it does take
time to build these products and set up
the sufficient channels and so on
now most people actually work at large
companies but frankly and large
conducive the same from they also want
to innovate so they have this advantage
that they have a big existing business
and you know so they can put new things
into the existing channels but the
disadvantages and they've plenty of
money right but the disadvantage is they
tend to focus on sort of more on the
past in the future
and we'll talk about this a little more
later on but between having lots of
Appeals which should be done and most of
business being legacy stuff it's
actually harder to integrate quickly in
large companies except if it's like the
best of best large companies then then
in small companies and this sort of to
the basic you know Mandela or ben de la
cuestión an industry which is how do you
actually accelerate envision do you
spend more on R&D you know do you do
more brainstorming do you do more focus
groups to elect more input so I wanted
to show some examples how how wrong
common assumptions are on these very
important topics so the first quiz
question is you know guess which high
tech company spends the least amount of
money on R&D on a percentage of sales
and profits you may know the answer it's
Apple and it's actually stunning their
spending is actually the best way to
look at it aren't used as a percent of
product margin which is how much money
we make Apple spends less than half of
you know the percentage of margin than
an HP one third of I IBM one fifth of in
law one third of Cisco and one 1/4 of
Microsoft roughly so how do they do it
well very simple
their whole corporate philosophy is you
know less is more simplify simplify
simplify
so Apple as you all know has the
simplest product line of any company in
the world they have exactly five
hardware products you know different
variations but basically is five
products and then some you know
beautiful software that supports all
this bet advice from the latest Steve
Jobs is you know the hardest thing in
life is to say no and they have done
this very successfully and have
essentially focused on the stuff that
matters now
they have been consultants that have
started this thing across all industry
there's a study from Booz Allen Hamilton
on
1,000 companies and they found no
correlation between R&D spending and
actually innovation success in the
market it's sad to say that's the case
it's basically the process of innovation
that comes not the pocketbook
now next quiz question is guess which
high-tech company spends the least
amount of effort with customers a focus
group to define their roadmap the same
answer this is a quote from Jonathan Ivy
their VP of senior VP of industrial
product design which says we don't
actually look to our customers for ideas
or for insurance that's what we're
working on will actually work we just
look we don't use for those groups we
just look at ourselves now having said
that you know it helps if you have
practice at this so what Apple really
has done at the end of the day is that
took ownership of innovation right that
basically said if the future is going to
be invented it's going to be invented
here in Cupertino and say no to
everything else right and then whatever
they're doing they're doing really
really well
so with these very simple you know
three-step formula here's the scum that
is not the most valuable company on the
planet and have arguably had some has
more had more innovation and more an out
change effect on people's behavior than
anyone else but the truth is not
everybody's Apple most companies are
much more complex they have thousands of
products you know take HP where they
have everything from nuts and bolts to
servers to laptops to you name it and in
many cases these companies have grown by
basically adding product lines or
increasing complexity which is a painful
way to grow but you know that's the
thing having said that you know every
company can still simplify so it advice
for big companies out there you know
simplify has its merits but going back
to you know this question of where do
the inventions the innovations actually
come from
so people have studied this as well then
the most likely place renovation is not
surprisingly the employees of the
company which would make sense right if
you're in the business you think about
this stuff every day you're trying to
solve these problems in a better way you
you are the source of innovation that
should drive the company forward now
business partners customers can be as
useful the customers a particular
problem that needs to be solved that's
inspiration of innovation things like
the actual R&D department is kind of way
on the list and academia slow but I
think that's because there's not that
much connection between
companies in academia Bev should be but
the truth is it's really the employees
that come up with the ideas right and
the what matters of course is to
translate these ideas to create new
products and that the perennial question
is why is this so hard in particularly
in large companies so it's a basic
problem of sort of funneling the best
ideas down and actually convert them to
execution what because at the
brainstorming stage you know things are
really easy or free no money is being
spent as you should design stuff and put
them into production a lot more money is
at stake and the spending pattern is
basically that almost no money is spent
on the invention stage for the inventor
invent something and great we invented
something new does she get this
invention to market costs more money
than the closer gets the market and
unfortunately the the focus in most
established companies is at the tail end
of this because that's where the money
is being spent so arguably not enough
time is spent on the front end where new
ideas are being generated and basically
companies need to pay more attention to
this discovery stage because without
invention you know nothing comes out at
the other end and then as this whole
prom of the ROI RI stands for return on
investment now the folks in the business
schools of the world and you know any
financial organization have perfected
this to spreadsheets you wouldn't
believe you know you can visit Island
you know market share market president's
marketing costs engineering costs you
name it and outcomes is this worth doing
well in if Apple had done this we
wouldn't have iPods or iPhones or
yesterday the simple reality is without
great products you cannot win in the
market so what matters much more than
the ROI for malice actually build
perfect products not to do the math
behind it and this leads to the next
topic which is the horizon effect so
this is something I learned about while
taking my first artificial intelligence
class and in AI it basically means that
if you have a limited search algorithm
like playing chess that can the computer
looks three steps ahead and you're good
move of the fourth move you will never
find it because you know it's beyond
your horizon and with limited search oh
of course you will never get the optimal
answer now applying this human
psychology is quite frankly nobody
really wants to
sooo goals beyond the horizon I mean
people don't do things if they don't see
how they get there and this was kind of
like the world was before Christopher
Columbus right nobody would go on that
ship going into the uncertainty of what
could happen now unfortunately in the
real world I'm talking you know Wall
Street Mannie here you know this is very
strong quarter-to-quarter mentality
where people are trying to make the
numbers every quarter and everything
that's being spent too much has to be
delayed or cut back or whatever to make
the numbers it is generally understood
that this is the greatest inhibition to
more creative initiatives in companies
because most people work in a company
are focused on the current the next to
the next few quarters out and that's how
it works now at the same token nobody
wants to start a project if you don't
have the resources to complete it but it
wouldn't make any sense it's just a
waste of time
so between so if the time arises in the
resource arising in particular if a
project is perceived to be risky a lot
of things just don't get off the ground
which is not the problem if in a startup
company where you pursued that new goal
but that's the permittivity heaven in
large companies so then the net result
of all of this is that most funding in
established companies is applied to safe
bets meaning things that are predictable
that have good or awry and very little
if any funding is applied to risky bets
except for some in our long term
research that usually doesn't have
anything do with the market this does
not accelerate innovation and to get
beyond this you know one has to if you
look at things a little further out and
focus on innovation that can actually
get stuff done that is effective and and
gets delivered so of course people
shouldn't bet everything on the future
and they can't bet everything on the
past so there has to be some
distribution of investments and I copied
from somebody's beautiful presentation
this curve that business says you want
to spend most of money on the safe
low-risk bets and then some on middle
things and then someone really radical
things but basically innovation comes
down to managing this curve but there
has to be stuff that is more
revolutionary that's further out and
even even while most spending is applied
to to less risky bets and you know it's
the companies that have managed this
curve effectively that really excel so
let's talk about then also you know why
do some of these great
tears fail including startups you know
that pursue them and believe I'm not
there's actually very few reasons why
startups fails there's BC only five
things I can think of the number one
reason is you're too early if you're too
early to market it doesn't help the
second one is you're too late you know
that doesn't help either
number three it's too difficult you just
couldn't get it done you know sort of
where it's just for not relevant to the
customer that's a really bad one or it
became too expensive there was no no
value proposition but those are the five
basic reasons why things don't succeed
now the inverse of that is if you are to
market at the right time with the right
product that's relevant and and has the
right sort of value of proposition it's
very likely if not predictable that it
actually will succeed so avoiding
failure is actually fairly easy in my my
book and then there's this whole other
risk is if you don't try things you know
you're not going to succeed anyway so
anyway there's no alternative to risk
something here so just a few examples of
companies of well-known companies that
have been doing things differently one
of course is Apple you know which was it
15 years ago was on the verge of
bankruptcy I mean this is truly one of
the most remarkable turnaround stories
in American history over Earth history
and expanded on very very successfully
from the initial you know iMac and Mac
books to iPads iPods iPhones iTunes and
all the beautiful things we know I think
what's particularly impressive is how
they combined a beautiful designed
hardware software with the internet
cloud so that you know loading your
applications loading music is just
transparent and and works like a snap
and and the success of all the things
speaks for itself
now if one looks behind the curtain a
little bit you know Apple obviously was
totally focused on that what you would
now call the digital consumer
opportunity which you know they always
wanted to do as a genetic kind of thing
and they were just the first company
that really focused on and did it really
well and then I stood that
simplification with the consumer was
absolutely key designing beautiful
products is of course also very
important but then this combination of
well-designed Hardware soft and cloud is
is what made the company and they've now
this you know internal Apple University
how they teach the new employers how to
invent
the next big thing so Apple has done
more was level and essentially had no
product feelin last 12 years
you know the whole corporate mission
asyou no innovation it's deeply
ingrained and result is the highest
market cap in the world Google is of
course the biggest search engine on
earth and it was that for for a while by
the way but the hit also the company has
expanded to many many areas beyond
search most recent to the Android kind
of smartphone systems the Chrome browser
scaling mark a rapid market share
YouTube of course has been a huge
success and so on now Google has a
somewhat different culture than Apple
which is they like to hire people right
out of school so they're not yet
entrenched with the wrong you know
indoctrinations I think they still have
this thing where you get one day a week
free to just think about stuff which
sounds like a good idea if it works and
they do claim that a lot of the best
ideas came out of that one day a week
thing but more importantly they set
themselves very very aggressive very
large circles basically they are trying
to solve where they expect that they can
solve the impossible problem that nobody
has solved before and this needs a lot
of smart people of course but they have
been doing this in the consistent
fashion so we would expect Google to
solve the next impossible thing that the
results is that you know it has been a
true innovation engine and ended up with
something like the third highest market
cap in the IT industry in the US and you
know we would obviously expect them to
do yet more great things in the future
now then a completely different company
Amazon so here's a company that started
off selling books on the Internet
very convenient you know you don't have
to go to the book store anymore and it's
cheaper but who would have guessed that
they have expended not just successfully
to other things they can ship but now
they are in electronic books the market
leader in ebooks and in magazines and
they are in fact the biggest cloud
service writer on the planet by a
longshot
so here's a compliment from you know
retailing books to reselling compute
cycles very successfully without losing
a bit a bit how did it do it now Jeff
basis is very keen on people who like a
rapid rate of change so that may be a
good thing because he likes change he
likes to keeps a lot of ideas
percolating
try a lot of ideas the same time see
what works and basically use tools and
structure to make the world a better
place so it worked which for them all of
these companies have have led with
innovation to define the current success
if these companies had not innovate an
ongoing basis there wouldn't be nearly
in the position that they are today and
and the same you know lessons can be
learned for other smaller companies
startup companies following these
particular very successful examples so
bottom line a culture of innovation
really helps paying attention to the
brainstorming you know front end face
avoiding the horizon effect basically
getting started with the projects that
really make the difference choosing an
appropriate risk profile not too much
risk but not not too little and then
focus focus focus to get this all done
since that at the end of the day you
know innovation is the never-ending
search for better solutions and there's
so many problems left out to solve you
know I wouldn't know how to start
but basically you know whether you think
about joining or you are at a small
company or a big one or start your own
company there's just a ton of
opportunities in in the world where in
that that need better solutions so I
think that's Alessa ahead thank you very
much for your attention
yeah can you elaborate on what you gave
my focus on the front end the thing is
once you get going with whatever project
you do right it's hard to change it
because you know people get sand up to
it emotionally and and money gets poured
in and it takes a famine of effort time
and money to do anything whether it's
you know hardware software you know
nanotubes whatever it is so the
important thing is to pick the right
projects because once you get going your
honor unlike a train basically and this
is even more important than instead of
companies where you typically only have
one chance to get it right I mean
there's a few startups that that pride
themselves of having you know change
crews in the middle but that's the rare
exception most common is that that have
went down the wrong direction will fail
so the most important thing is to pick
the right project that makes the big
difference that you can achieve that you
have to write expertise and the right
people that can make it happen the right
tools I mean all of these things play
together so basically it's understanding
the the problem in the market that needs
to be solved that needs a better
solution the best technology that can be
applied to that from hardware software
cloud whatever and then getting it done
efficiently and delivering it to
customers so it's a very predictable
cycle actually it's just when you start
on the wrong wrong track you know you
never finish I don't know too
specifically but you know there's a lot
of companies stops out there with where
the funders say we have no idea what
we're doing I don't believe that I think
they usually knew exactly what they're
doing so it's the rare case where the
people stumble on something you know as
they go along it's usually well thought
out from the beginning not a question
you should like to find two reasons why
a company Dell so how do you assess the
risk part of the age yeah let me let me
go actually said this is pips the most
important slide in this talk here you
know timing is everything
in other words different examples of
great ideas that that happen at the
right time but they wouldn't have worked
out if it was just six months later or
six months sooner in fact Sun
Microsystems the reason I dropped out of
Stanford quite frankly was you know I
had a choice I could finish my PhD or I
could start this company so the
trade-off was if I had waited another
six months or so the company that
opportunity may have been gone so my
father time was I start a company then I
come back and finish the PhD later but I
never came back so sorry I'm not
encouraging by the way anybody to drop
out of Stanford I don't think that's
valid that would be good advice but what
is true is that you know the some of the
most successful companies out there
including the Google software will start
at exactly the right time if they hadn't
had that insight or the cheap hardware
or the the Linux or whatever they needed
to build that website with they could
they couldn't have done what they're
doing two years earlier or - you said it
would have been too late or even one
year and one year later so most great
ideas had a very specified horizon where
they actually worked what you see is the
biggest threats to this innovation well
it's not much 300 technology said so let
me say up front you know as long as the
chip companies are not running out of
money to fund new factories that can
drive more slow down so that that would
be a separate form but assuming that
continues there will be better chips and
you know cheaper compute cycles and more
memory for the next many many years
which drives cost performance and
enables new kind of products to be built
there's no shortage of smart people
there's a lot smarter in this room it is
this great university so it you know the
expertise and the technology basically
exists there's lots of promissory Assaf
so none of those are risk factors one of
the minor risk factors is that the whole
venture capital cycle is a little more
difficult these days because it's
basically harder to go public so B C's
had a harder time to get the money back
out of the investments and this is to do
with you know S or X regulations and
other
basically go public it says you have to
be a large company wears in the old days
you know you could be a much smaller
company and raise money and grow more
quickly so that is this slight negative
but it's not a Schuster but the best
ideas are still getting funded and below
us get funded and there's as much
venture capital being spent now as they
were spent five years ago so it's you
know the is venture capital available
sometimes it's allocated to certain
areas more than others for example a few
years ago Green Tech was a really hot
thing red until it became here that you
know making solar cells is actually
cheaper in China or you know 15 years
ago I think graphics chip was a really
hot topic so there was actually 30
graphics chips company in the mid 90s
and the only one that really made it was
actually Nvidia who is you know the
founders one said this this building so
basically in that worse I guess social
networking is still a hot topic now this
they still come is getting funded to do
different kinds of social networking
although it actually may be too late to
get up against Facebook so the best
thing is to be at the beginning of one
of these curves not try to emulate
something people have done you know yes
earlier so it's usually the new problems
that are the most promising to solve not
some legacy prom but people are still in
a moving databases to the cloud I mean
that's this big efforts going on to
convert all of conventional IT to a
cloud service business and that this is
a huge total market opportunity so the
companies that are good at that will do
really well no question well that was
too early that's it's the whole thing
which is the early Newton a diminishing
lot but also the the Palm Pilot and the
officer completo seen before that Yeoh
or go go which became here you know the
only this notion that you know you could
use the stylus which already was a
mistake because you know you always lose
the stylus and then that the compelling
benefit was essentially of an electronic
note put notepad where you could take
notes or look up your addresses or
something like that and that just wasn't
a compelling use model right if you know
music was useful because people love to
listen to music and being connected by
phone is very useful or by the but a net
to have your email so the first thing
that would actually that really combined
you know email browsing web browsing and
in the conventional phone with all the
other applications was in fact the
iPhone
the previous things just didn't have a
big enough screen or didn't have the
same use one the the old pawn phones you
know that the tiny keyboard I mean my
daughter thought was good for her
because she could travel to say I never
knew how to use this verse you know a
lot of it has to do with usability so
basically all prior things before iPod
iPad and iPhone just weren't that
user-friendly and you know apples most
remarkable achievement is to make it
that simply use that people there's no
more manual right you take the thing out
of the box you turn it on it now it
works in the old days people had to read
the manual first it was a big change but
it seems that that one of the main
lessons you're having is that somehow
Moore's law goes on automatically and
research and development every corner
now so what did people in the business
world mean when they say research and
development to me researches innovation
and development is you know making
better chips Sonya you throw a region
and development are you just leopard
marketing mistress Cerf right in
traditional companies the vast majority
of R&D goes into the existing products
and and rightfully so red mean like say
you're on the inner car business right
you make another car you know it has a
size different shape or maybe some new
radio whatever but it's not that much
change from the last year's car right
you still you spend a lot of money
tooling it up and perfecting it or
whatever but it's really hard to make a
big change and gambling on electric cars
hasn't worked out for most people
whereas in high-tech you know the real
risk is that you don't invent the next
big thing so of course I mean a
traditional company like say it's an
Oracle company they have to get the
database perfect perfect perfect and if
there's any book they still have to fix
that but then to completely change that
model to a different kind of say Hadoop
data analytics makes you be difficult
for them because that's just not where
their home turf is right and that
enables new companies to do data mining
grand scale which is very different a
traditional structured kind of data base
so it's more an example of where the
Denisov changes underneath you and your
existing products no longer it could
match to that and what you really need
is a very different kind of product that
it's just optimized for the new problem
to be solved
so this lots of opportunities in Big
Data right now where I disappear not
enough people graduating that know this
stuff for all the employers who want to
hire these people I mean it's one of
these shortages of talent and industry
the combination of statistics and
understanding method modeling on large
data sets but I'm sure you know some of
them some of those people may be in the
room here so it's again let me say is
different the reason that a start-up can
even compete or ever get successful
against an established company right
which is not a normal thing is that it's
focused on this one you think that
really made a difference that they
become they missed out on that that's
the natural law here it and if there's
no thing so the starter come is a
fraction of the resources in terms of
R&D of the big company but the big
company spends ninety seven percent of
the resources on legacy stuff so the
real investment even a large company
makes in future things is single-digit
small percentages and as a start-up you
can actually compete with that level of
investment surprisingly because you're
spending 100 percent of your venture
capital dollars on the new thing and
you're spending zero on the old stuff so
that is what makes the the venture model
even work otherwise it would never work
absolutely do science cloud computing
what do you think of the top five areas
that need innovation some of this has to
do with you know are you talking about
startup versus become me but let me see
is definitely every company large or
small has to innovate in whatever field
they're in to not fall behind so that
goes without saying that the companies
that are growing the fastest are the
ones that actually consistently drive
innovation in whatever field in and let
me talk just for one second on my my
latest startup called Arista networks
which is you know not the subject of
this talk but you know we have now a
midsize business in about 450 employees
2050 engineers but and we have a decent
revenue stream but our real challenge is
how do we get to a billion dollars one
day so we are meaningful so that our
innovation is how do we grab market
share from much more established
companies and
defrayed the kind of product we're
building to to gain this kind of ramp
you know and keep growing on this ramp
you're on so every company has a
different problem if you will where they
need to innovate so our focus is on this
you know particular rampion other people
are focused on big data analytics or
solving problems that have been solved
before so there's no simple answer but
from a start-up I don't know return on
investment model obviously the best
opportunities is where there's a future
large market opportunity that hasn't
been discovered yet because then even as
a start-up can grow very big so those
are the best cases but even a
decent-sized market opportunity is a
very valuable thing to go after what you
don't want to go after it's just some
tiny opportunity that never really pans
out so the opportunity has to be there
because that's sort of the payoff at the
end of the day but there's no simple
formula that says you know that
investing right now say and
virtualization technology is more better
than in cloud stuff or big data right
you have to be the the expert in your
particular field and have the knowledge
of the you know competitive environment
in that micro segment of the market that
you're gonna pursue and truly understand
why you think that one that the thing
that you're building is going to be
better than all the other things that
already exist or that other people may
be building so once you have that
insight you know you're usually ona on a
good path and you have the confidence
because you did all this market research
and that knowledge of the technologies
that you know you can get there and that
the confidence and attracts people who
want to join you and and the whole thing
sort of takes off and once in the role
it's easier to hire people but very
early on you know some people may wonder
is it's gonna make it or not so we're
resource to companies to explain to the
next end people you know what's gonna
work so more questions the part of
innovation especially for high-risk
innovation there's a large failure rate
so I was taken aback when you said that
Apple has not had a failure from the
past 12 years but they've been the most
innovative companies but luring a
thoughts on that well they had a
particular quit process and and I don't
know anymore about Apple than I've
written you know in Steve Jobs biography
but it's clear that you know they're
very you know they had lots of
discussions lots of meetings about what
should they do they would test this with
themselves first or they had this whole
lab but they would look at every
alternative product design and then pick
the best ones it was a very methodical
process that appears to be unlike other
companies
and clearly that was a big part of the
success and I was driven by that by the
people they are led by the CEO and the
Joan relief is stay there now instill
this in their cultures so much that they
will keep going in this way so that's
certainly I would go for but going back
to Feiler one one good thing about
Silicon Valley is that you know it's not
the end of the day if a particular
startup fails in fact you know people
are very good about deciding whether
there was a market failure a product a
failure or saw a lack in effort we have
spread you know good people who started
completed fields have every chance to go
to another company that succeeds wares
in other countries quite frankly you
know if you borrow money from so many
other bankers from one in your fail then
you have to pay back the money that
disappeared for the next you know 30
years you're basically you know you
can't do anything else so I do
understand like in India this is
particularly rough like any you can't
lose anybody's money so this that's this
one reason to disappear
relatively few startups in India at the
high risk stage whereas here you know if
it's long as the venture complex still
trust you after the first flop you know
you can actually still succeed but in an
event you know people who work at a
company that doesn't go near it can
always go to another company there's
hundreds of startups in this valley
right so there's no career risk about
joining the wrong company but you don't
want to do is the state accommodate
along that isn't going anywhere because
that would actually be a bigger negative
in their career so if it doesn't work
out you might as well go to to a better
company but generally speaking
this is an investment fish so what what
would you really do when you invest in
public companies is you you know you
take a certain market risk of it most
stock was actually market related I hate
to say it this way but if the market
goes up everything goes up if market
goes down everything doesn't it I think
half of all motions work related and
then it's the company element which is
this company doing better than a market
right what the industry segments the
companies in is that doing better than
the market so you can have a return a
high return on investment if you have
the right company in the right market
segment and the market goes up right but
that is much more even in the average
the the stock index now is the same
where it was ten years ago so the
average index hasn't done anything right
on the end if you bought Apple shares
ten years ago you would be very happy
now let's do this this is this big gap
in terms of identifying what stocks
working out and a lot of people on Wall
Street spend the whole life trying to do
that and some of them are more
successful than others but it's a weird
way to spend time basically so I rather
build better products on the other hand
to add your question when the investors
in successful new companies if them
particularly well read if they picked
the right startups so that goes without
saying that some of the highest return
on investments have been new companies
including for the employees in the
company right so that that is the whole
magic formula second value it's a
completely different risk this is just a
risk of making it as a startup and then
getting acquired it will go public one
day which is very different than a big
company where people throw it really
hard to improve you know 10 20 % a year
but the stock is still the same because
the market went down 20%
I'm not explain this but I doubt it's
it's successful and let me tell you why
basically when you start a company I
mean it depends what kind of competence
if you do like a iPhone app you can do
that by yourself over three buddies you
know you can do that on your credit card
later you don't need any money if you
want to build something bigger and you
need a million dollars then or
settlement dollars it gets a lot harder
because it's it might be an unlikely
that crowdsourcing or crowdfunding Bill
wanna you know
only up millions of dollars and the
issue is if you don't even of money to
get to your target you might as well not
start because you're not going to finish
right so you have to have enough funding
or at least a path to the funding that
allows you to be successful
otherwise it's it's all wasted so
krottas funding may work for the smaller
kind of ideas but it's not going to work
for for larger companies well you know
we what is true is that you know we also
very much customer to referee meaning we
basically do the things we need to do
for requesters customers have new
protocols new features and that is the
biggest acceleration to our business is
just to do more of the same which is a
proven business model but if the
business were to change completely which
I don't think it is but you know that
that would be a more challenging thing
for us because there would mean to have
to do something else so as long as we do
what we're doing the business stay
stable we can actually RAM predictably
but if there was a for any reason to
rapid change in the market that would be
challenging for any company including
for us and if you have an opinion on the
importance of the patents and protecting
innovation so whether recent changes in
the law you know that's that's a very
sore topic the I don't know basically
you know it costs very little to file a
patent you know you can file it yourself
and so I think a $20 filing fee or
whatever it costs a lot of money to
assert a patent or to defend against a
patent so basically if your company and
somebody accuses you have a patent
violation or you want to accuse somebody
else over patent relation the the bill
for that sort of lawsuit is men's and
men's of dollars depending how extensive
it gets so this is something you know
big companies do a lot because they want
to you know assert their rights against
others but for for startups you know
basing your strategy on and obviously
you can use patents to defend what you
have right but to assert them is a very
expensive proposition and usually only
makes sense if you're big companies so
it's I guess it's a good idea to file
patents we have a whole bunch but it's
very hard to actually monetize them or
or assert them unless you have a really
deep pockets
when you google did you know if you
foresee that the company will be very
good today yeah I don't think anybody
goes so they found us whether we but
what was hit to me is that they couldn't
go broke because I thought there would
be enough people clicking on the links
that they would actually pay for there
would be at break-even very quickly
which is what they did but the fact that
it then around so quickly just nobody
foresaw anything myself
perspective with respect to IBM and
innovation and extremely large company
in your thought your annum so you know
IBM is a interesting company because
from all the big IT companies they have
the most you know research labs and have
invested very heavily in in innovation
particular both at the software level
and and sort of hardware things so it is
an example that you can drag innovation
as a very large company but I think
still somewhere iBM is wondering how
they're missing other more things that
are happening in Silicon Valley right so
there's this sort of gap between us or
to become here we can place big bets but
the the prom for like I mean it's like
honeybee law company right so for them
if it doesn't do like a billion dollars
it doesn't move the needle right so they
tend to miss the smaller opportunities
like a 10 minute opportunity which is a
great thing for starter but you muhanad
mendala one because it only gets
interested in but it gets big enough to
actually make a difference and they can
almost buy the startup so they tend to
perhaps move more cautious than you
things once it's more proven but it's
also a company that's willing to do that
for the the right opportunities
including a lot of software lately cars
there was a slight issue where you give
percentage of ideas coming from
different segments of people employees
research dollars how much do you believe
in that slide and if you had money to
spend in a large company where would you
spend well you could you spend in that
proportion you know the promise B
companies is that you have so many ideas
and so many people that all want to
promote ideas and it seems like a good
idea but some people more risk-averse
than others you get this almost like
cacophony of voices of what to do
so I think one reason for Apple success
is that that a much more streamlined
sort of management structure and
basically one decision make on the top
and you know done deal right that
actually can work much better as long as
those are the right decisions then any
other approaches were sort of democratic
if you know what I mean and it's it's
just a question how companies operate
internally now there's counter examples
for example 3m which is not a computer
company has a pin Lee very well
organized around multiple business units
that you know invents scotch tape here
and other things there and then many
many different businesses like that so
it depends on the type of company but in
IT companies you know the the different
voices can be quite amazing you know
like we mentioned you are at HP right
now with what three and fifty thousand
employees and the question is what to do
it you would go more into software and
what the services more into hardware
where do you increase investment to
decrease investment those are very tough
choices and many people have many
different opinions but you're going to
spend a lot of time on that question and
you may miss the next little thing that
turns into a big thing so it every
company has just different you know
reason for existence and it's a
different situation here but I do
believe that employees are your biggest
asset that goes without saying but so in
any company it's usually the employees
that broke on the stuff that they find
the strategy that get it done let's say
I can do this or we shouldn't do this
you know it's also important potential
may be saying this can't be done that
drives the success the other people
execute the engineering so one has to
pay close attention them as well as the
customers because ultimately what you're
building is to resonate with the
ultimate customer
if you were to be advising some of the
engineering students today felt to focus
and get very very specific narrow it
down or would you say get focused but
almost put put something out and study
other fields just to get across today
yeah that's that's no chunk of somebody
Vic she talked to us at dinner earlier
which is you know if your interests are
very narrow and you really want to
specialize in say Hadoop big data for
right now Brett you're a highly
desirable employee to a lot of companies
so you have sort of you you can choose
where you want to go to you know any any
number of companies whereas if you're
not sure what you actually want to do
and you have more the journalist you're
still interested in many companies but
you wouldn't be as vertically aligned
with a particular one so it's actually
easier for the prisoners very vertically
to make a choice you know in both
directions they're complete using the
person use your same company then a
person's more journalists right but you
know the real lives of journalists
people so that they truly narrow people
that that really excel something are
that they're rare of reach via behind
but they usually the ones who actually
start the company because they're so
convinced that they know how to do this
take it just get it done so in my own
case right I've been vertically down to
build this workstation and I just did it
by myself essentially and it was you
know smooth sailing afterwards but if I
didn't have that focus I could have
never done it so the founder when he
went off to Weezie's to get funding
sewers rejected like 30 times before
there's a lot of stories of people's
value which are typically not Stanford
graduates but you know people have all
kinds of business plans or business
ideas and I should know so much of
myself you know they keep trying to get
their plan funded right and if it
doesn't get funny they come up with
another plan and they just keep churning
what plans until if get one that gets
fun it's like scripts in Hollywood right
if the first script doesn't make it you
write another one and eventually it
becomes a movie that's that's not the
recommendation you can spend a lot of
time doing that you have to pick
something that has real value you know
to future customers and where you the
exponent
to succeed more quickly and those fans
to get the better plans so the ones
where people go round and round and not
know not the government's but back to
intuit it was really good idea and maybe
you know people misjudged the value of
the idea and this you know it has
happened in other segments you know
Facebook early on didn't get a lot of
funding because people thought I was
crazy but in the end you know I really
thought they wanted to be part of this
so question so it seems to me like in
the early days of the ARPANET most of
the things the innovations and things
came because people kind of ignored it
but now it's become billions of dollars
business so it's starting to aggregate
into a few companies and the government
also becoming a lot more controlling so
do you think that's gonna kill the
chicken that's been laying the golden
egg and the innovation and the web and
the internet see sir yes let me insist a
little different it's just back then it
wasn't fixed easier to start a company I
want it at your first hand the reason
was that the existing large companies
were not early adopter of the new
technologies I mean I be made the
mainframe digital equipment had the mini
computer but they were very comfortable
with these businesses and it didn't see
the threat below right whereas if you
try to start a company today in those in
business you would be up against you
know Microsoft and Intel and and video
or anybody it's really is actually a
startup company it is very successful at
it today so that competition is much
tougher then it was competing against
IBM Dec and HP in the earliest of Sun
for example so so it would be it would
permit little sense today to start
another server company because you know
sir margins are declining and it's just
not a promising field you know so to
speak whereas most companies have missed
a social network increase so there's a
certain area people investing or the
next big thing with big data so you have
to pick a thing that's ahead of the
mainstream adoption it is very tough to
I mean you wouldn't write a new
operating system they do compete against
Microsoft or Linux quite thank you IT
companies and things restrict you know
only the big customers get there
surgically
yeah that's a different form which is
you know some customers just want to
have the full support of a large vendor
and it's hard to break into those
accounts if that's your business
strategy you have to have a real value
proposition that gets you through there
that that's one of the more difficult
it's Tuesdays you know exponential and
you know 2,000 years ago somebody would
understand living a thousand years ago
but somebody 200 years ago wouldn't
understand an iPhone and you know how is
that going to affect society well I'm
not sure it's exponential so let me
saying is this that yes there's data has
no explanation no question there right
but this what the data is actually
useless so the heart from these days is
truly the heart from is filtering I
promise ok and of course people growing
up today right they grow up with an
iPhone or iPad you know I have a
completely different experience of what
it means to Venus feel so you know my
daughter was used to the iPod and we're
driving the car and this thing was
already for a change did you like the
song just can it play the song again and
I had to explain to her I cannot replay
the radio because it's not an iPod she
was three so the but the point is you
know the the the the truly good ideas I
mean if even if you look back the last
10 years right there was the
consumerization of the digitalization of
the consumer experience it was a truly
great idea we're not going to see
another consumerization of digital the
same thing the next 10 years now
hopefully we can see the cloud adoption
of enterprise computing in other
consumer cell that is like pointing
click to install an enterprise
application that would be nice today it
takes weeks if not months to configure a
new server storage network to solve a
problem in the data center why is this
so complicated well there has been so
many companies erecting walls to make
that impossible that that's what it is
but that's actually not what the
customer wanted right it doesn't solve
the customer problems we need you know
software-defined data centers something
that it works a lot easier than what it
works today no question right and again
the question is will this innovation
come from you know VM VR IBM or from
startups and maybe it's all of the above
right because it's a big problem to
solve an existing vendors are tend to
want to defend their home turf quite
frankly
you know they try to extend the business
and and extend reach out but they don't
want to change it completely either they
can't so it's you know that's the
interesting dynamics which is what's if
you think of this whole as thing as a
chess game right it's like what what are
the moves you can make as a startup what
are the most these bigger other existing
business can do and how do you play this
game so you're gonna win that it's it's
really is an intellectual chess game in
at that level and the strategy is you
know it's move by move doing the right
things what you're worried for it's a
potential permit there's a certain error
rate to data on transmission or
otherwise and you need fairly strong CRC
codes and ECC codes to to prevent that
from happening or at least make it
visible when it happens and be able to
correct it and this is true you know
with its flash memory or laser
communication it is it's it's a general
prominent industry now the logic gates
are still pretty robust luckily so if
logic gates get flaky that's that's
actually bigger prone but with
corruption is essentially dealt with by
strong hash checksums I'm not right
about the decryption sir although I
sometimes wonder if some dealer
disappears with it you know how could
this happen
so those things definitely
yeah let me discuss briefly wide it is
and in this section I cut out these
slides because I thought I was getting
too technical so the speed of the
transistors is not doubling every other
year unfortunately in fact it's barely
going up so when you talk about the the
i/o you notice the pins that come out of
the chip that one said drive the laser
progress is like effective to every five
years which is much much much slower
than Moore's law so so chips are going
to be increasingly i/o limited in terms
of there's only so much I owe and the
i/o doesn't go up with Moore's law so
people are working now on you know
optics on the chip silicon photonics to
get more stuff off the chip and and I
think that's coming along but that could
be a limitation except the silicon
photonics people think you know deafness
from soft when it when it gets there but
you know the it doesn't mean that
networking for example is not on the
same price performance improvement as is
CPUs because you're actually not
doubling every year unfortunately but
going back to one thing that it's not
something I'm very about but something
I'm wondering about him just to set this
bit in your mind here is what seems
clear to me is that the the development
of chip technology by the time it's
getting as dense as it's gonna get you
know it sooner or later it will equal
the number of cells we have in our human
brain you know socially at the numeric
level so the fundamental question that
has never really been solved is how one
could build computers that work more
like the brain literally than the
traditional phenomen model and this does
require a lot of parallelism apparently
and a lot of you know and law kind of
functions and God knows what else but
that would be very real worth to spend a
lot of R&D on right now because to me
this is the kind of problem that could
be solved in the next ten years where's
ten years ago that was I've been too
difficult the chip technologists wasn't
there but you know there's only so many
brain cells in the brain and you know
the future chips are going to be just as
dense so this something whose time may
come in and not-too-distant future so if
I was a student right now that's what I
would be working on is this a thought
for the evening
you